we have
more reason to believe
that the most serious investigation of
the attempts to steal the 2020 election
are happening in georgia
the fake electors
have now been subpoenaed in georgia and
we're going to talk about it this is
correct this is a good thing but to
contextualize
i've continued to insist
that the most likely
orange or origin
of charges high-level criminal charges
against the top people in the trump
administration
are most likely to come from the georgia
investigation that's the one where
donald trump famously said on the phone
i need hundred and seven eleven thousand
seven hundred and eighty votes give me a
break that's the one where lindsey
graham the senator from south carolina
called to see well what could be done
there that's the one that really seems
most obviously criminal and most
provably criminal and that georgia
investigation continues to signal that
it is the most likely place where
charges may stem nbc news reporting
georgia fake electors hit with subpoenas
in criminal probe this move indicates
the district attorney is homing in on
potential charges related to the alleged
plot by trump's team to overturn the
2020 election nearly a dozen of
georgia's fake electors revealed tuesday
they've been subpoenaed to appear before
the fulton county special grand jury
hearing evidence in the criminal
investigation into 2020 interference by
trump and his allies the revelation came
in a court filing where attorneys for 11
of the state's 16 false presidential
electors tried to quash subpoenas
calling them unreasonable and oppressive
the attorneys also argued that fulton
county d.a fannie willis's office
initially said their clients were
witnesses not subjects or targets and
that they agreed to voluntary interviews
although it appears as though that has
changed this is a very good sign it
seems fanny willis is taking this
extraordinarily seriously
it appears that on august 2nd unless
something changes senator lindsey graham
is going to have to appear and testify
not as a target that we know but this is
a brazen and direct attempt to subvert
the will of the people to subvert
democracy it was authoritarian and it
was fascistic the plot was and this
happened in multiple states what do
david fake electors what do you mean
it's some is it a fake person like it's
a mannequin what do you mean now here's
what i mean
joe biden won georgia
and because joe biden won georgia
georgia's electoral votes go to joe
biden when you count and try to get to
270 votes which is what you need to
become president
georgia and all states won by joe biden
say put ours
in the biden column and then you add
them up and if you get to 270 you become
president
the scam that among others
trump was running in georgia and other
states was
just
put together a slate of republican
electors have them all sign oh we the
duly undersigned are indeed the electors
and we cast our electoral votes for
donald trump even though trump didn't
win the state that was the idea and it's
being investigated in a serious manner
in uh wisconsin it's being investigated
in a serious manner in arizona maybe in
other states as well i don't have the
full list in front of me and in georgia
and in georgia
fannie willis wants to know
who organized you this was a thing where
there was an elector a fake elector in
arizona confronted by a reporter
and he said was this part of like a big
plan
and the fake elector was evasive and
didn't really say anything he was like
no i just showed up
well how did you know
where to go and when to show up you
might say well i believe trump won but
if you want to show up and try to sign
fake elector forms someone clearly told
you where to go and when to go if i
wanted to be a fake elector i wouldn't
just go to the dmv on tuesday at 10 i
would someone would tell me this is
where we're meeting to sign papers who
was that and the guy refused to answer
and eventually walked away so fannie
willis is taking this seriously in
georgia the electors have been
subpoenaed they are going to have to
appear unless something changes and
maybe we will get answers as to how high
up was the organization of these fake
electors very important
huge
this is one of the things where we spoke
to a lawyer
uh involved in this in wisconsin last
week and he agreed
thankfully
a number of safeguards prevented these
alternate electors from being considered
legitimate and valid
but in theory if you had a motivated
governor and the right things in place
they could say yeah well we don't
believe biden won we believe trump won
and so we're certifying the republican
electors instead and then you would have
a hellish situation on your hands so we
are going to follow this closely we'll
tell you when they'll be testifying and
what is likely to come of it in the
meantime find me on twitter at deepakman
and remember that we have the next david
pakman show viewer town hall coming up
on tuesday
july 26th
at 6 p.m eastern
it will stream exclusively on our second
youtube channel pacman
and we'll be taking questions from
everybody i hope you'll participate more
on that later this week
who doesn't love a good cereal the
crunchiness the sweetness it satisfies
in a serious manner but then you grow up
and now all the healthy cereals are
boring and bland and they get soggy and
this is where magic spoon comes in it is
that sweet crunchy texture you loved
from childhood with zero grams of sugar
only four to five net carbs perfect if
you're doing keto only 140 calories per
serving and packed with 14 to 15 grams
of protein magic spoon spent years
developing the recipes it's really the
only cereal on the market to get the
texture and the flavor right without the
sugar and without a ton of carbs they
have flavors like cocoa honey nut fruity
peanut butter maybe you want to go
adventurous they've got blueberry muffin
maple waffle cookies and cream or
cinnamon roll that brings back memories
i love magic spoon the whole team does
but if you don't you'll get a full
refund but i know it's about to become
your new favorite cereal you'll get five
dollars off when you go to
magicspoon.com
pacman the link is down below